وفي الاخير في صوره لطفل سوري بمحافظه حلب
جسد معنا الصمود والامل بصوره وهو بيبيع
غزل البنات وسط الدمار ومبتسم وكانه بوصل
رساله انه الحياه مستمره والامل موجود
وبما انه بنتكلم عن الاطفال والزلزال ففي
جانب كنا تناولناه من قبل وهو اثر الزلزال
النفسي على الناس بمختلف اعمارهم وحتى ان
كانوا جايبين منه او بعاد ففي معلمه تركيه
بتشرف على عدد من الاطفال اللي تشردوا
موجودين ضمن عباره في ميناء الاسكندرون
تحولت لمستشفى ميداني لاحظ التاثر الاطفال
بالزلزال وسيطرته على عقولهم فالاطفال
هناك بداوا يلعبوا لعبه اسمها الزلزال
فبيعملوا بنب العابهم بيسالوا بعض اذا كان
هذا البنا حيتحمل الزلازل او لا وغير
اللعبه مجسمات وسيارات الاطفاء اللي
بيستخدموها كمان خلال لعبهم عشان يروحوا
لمنطقه الزلزال ويساعدوا الناس طبعا خلال
اللعبه طبعا وفي اخصائيه نفسيه كمان في
نفس المكان قالت انه في اطفال بيعانوا من
صعوبه في النوم ونوبات البكاء المفاجاه
[موسيقى]